because I read it in Empire magazine
that you've been watching all the MCU
Marvel movies these days what was your
reaction to seeing the reference to
Ezekiel on the gravestone of Nick Fury
in I think I want to say Winter Soldier
yeah yeah someone just tells you yeah it
must be just like there I am again yeah
I had no idea it was coming but there we
are well I knew it was coming because I
ended up watching Sam Jackson on the
Jimmy Fallon show and Jimmy Fallon
mentioned it because oh for the
Tarantino fans out there there's this
big thing
well the fact that I grew up with Marvel
comic books and you know uh the Marvel
Universe before it was a Cinematic
Universe when it was just basically a
Stanley uh Jack Kirby and Roy Thomas's
uh web spinning
Enough Said So the fact that all of a
sudden my universe was now being quoted
inside of as close the gate as the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is felt pretty
good